Oh PewDiePie he's running out of ideas
oh it's so obvious papayas running out
of fresh ideas oh yeah
well there is what I still got one card
one card left to play the most desperate
card in all of you I never thought I
would sink this low
I'm disgusted what kind of clickbait
title could we put on this one I just
ask me anything
just pretty pot do drugs that's the
title of the video now everyone that's
the title of the video oh you noticed if
we have some guests in the studio here
today clap it up everyone
we have Emma blackery giant flex we have
cinnamon toast can everybody and let's
not forget our special
[Music]
[Applause]
accurate accurate size we also have me
here no I'm not compensating for a
measly shut the [ __ ] up look how
beautiful please Felix don't put me in
the ceiling shut up Felix you going in
the [ __ ] ceiling I don't have any
question just want you to delete a happy
wheels video what the hell man
what the hell you try your best I feel
like we need some sad music for this cuz
which one should we go with alright
episode 53 it's been that spin goodbye
you're out you're out
alright next question next question
comes from Brad one of my editors will
you let my family go
I've worked hard enough I'll leave this
one to the game-mode team unfortunately
Brad's family has suffered Stockholm
Syndrome and wish to stay with Felix
forever well well well alright episode
60 euro out of all the people in the
world what made you choose me to be in
your background wait Ainsley Harriott
way is this real is that the real end
slate what but he was he was dead ah
Ainsley it's a real person anyway
episode 41 has been nice spin nice necks
quits
next question kiss me Felix you're not
I'm not gonna spider-man kiss you ask
boots smash or pass JK rowling
I'm gonna have to let the gang take care
of that one what's that sound to slavery
sell that [ __ ] stirs ivory it's really
offensive to say to shell someone to
slavery Felix you don't understand the
history and the struggles that JK
Rowling went through Jacob Rowling used
to be very cold and then she wrote some
books then she became my whiny [ __ ] on
Twitter you don't understand her
struggle alright [ __ ] I keep forgetting
I have to delete a [ __ ] video like
it's not funny why did I come up with
this idea isn't that any value to the
video which one which one do you think I
think I think it's time for like one of
the earlier ones someone somewhere right
now is going like that Trump lady at the
inauguration about me deleting these
videos goodbye episode 11
[Music]
can you reenact the my name Jeff scene
from 22 Jump Street no no I'm not gonna
do that what do I look like some sort of
[ __ ]
I've been practicing I've been
practicing a lot for this my name why
does no one love me because you're
wearing Hitler glasses they you're
wearing not a fascist glasses okay no
you little bit you know you're a bit
young but you need to you need to not do
that because that's why no one loves you
when will you watch the true epic love
story that is Hashi pie what is this
[Music]
you guys are [ __ ] weird you guys are
good at editing and I appreciate your
thing thank you very nice now I finally
have some fapping material I've been
been running out for a while guess now
we have to delete another [ __ ] video
god [ __ ] dead 3121 so dad it's not a
meme that a meme right that's a mean do
you think phil lester deserves more
appreciation uh no I think he's a little
overrated I I would like to say that I'm
more of a damn man if you know what I
mean goodbye
episode seven you guys want 2012
PewDiePie back yeah well I want 2012
YouTube back ok so much badder Tala
means sit down why is Emma blackery so
big like what happened here I don't
understand Emma do you have anything to
say to you this is the first time we
collab on this channel what would you
like to say you're gay I'm gay
Wow I'm so sick of deleting these
[ __ ] things like why did I why am I
still here like this one [ __ ] had 4
million views life's not fair life's not
fair when will you kill yourself
another happy wheels video no not
episode 3 not episode 3 ask kids read
this to die instantly yes yes my time to
shine are you the reincarnation of Adolf
Hitler I can neither I can neither
confirm or deny in episode 10 goodbye do
you miss the simpler things in life
after gaining huge popularity it's
honestly not that different if you
follow me throughout the throughout an
entire day I think you'll realize that
I'm pretty much doing whatever you're
doing and I'm pretty much the same you
know I think you'd be pretty overwhelmed
though how boring my life actually it's
behind the scenes
I only snored a couple pounds of cocaine
every day only a couple hookers not five
or six every night and and that's
another happy wheels video do you love
make sexed with martha or no or are you
thinking to bring maybe i imagine that's
how they wanted it well that's another
happy wheels video that was thank you
for that thank you appreciate the great
question not thinking to bring any
babies no I I do not I was doing just
fine before I met you I drink too much
and that's an issue okay your friends it
was nice to meet them
I've never see them again
I know that's cold bro damn that's
really [ __ ] cold
here's no now you're looking good today
that was it take forever
hi can you slow dance with sleepy
[Music]
I'm scared and that's another happy
wheels alright and final question can
you do a back flip no now we're gonna
have a silent moment for all the lost
happy wheels videos alright then so
leave it like if you enjoyed this video
if you did Ken its gonna do something
really funny if you could click it right
now and so he's something really fun
it's gonna happen any moment any moment
at any moment